this is gonna sound like a strange
question but how would you advise
mentally preparing for the horrors of
war like if you knew someone you cared
about what's going to be on the
frontlines what would you tell him I
would tell them to detach you know I
would tell them to detach I would tell
them to do their job but don't get all
caught up in it because that's what you
have to do you if you go in the front
lines and you know right now there's a
bunch of doctors and nurses going on the
front lines and hospitals and that can
be emotionally overwhelming look they do
that for a living but when you see
overcrowded or whatever's happening you
could see where people might be
overwhelmed by that or their health at
risk so they're overwhelmed by that so
do your job but you've got to stay
detached from it don't get all caught up
in it and also I would say I would tell
them look it's it's oh if the emotions
that you're gonna have are okay and it's
normal you're gonna feel scared you're
gonna feel disgusted you're gonna feel
horrified you're gonna feel sick all
those things are all those things are
normal
they're normal feelings that you're
gonna have when you are seeing this side
of humanity for the first time I would
say I would tell them to write down and
talk about what they see what they hear
what they feel with other people because
if you try and keep them contained
inside your own head you won't process
them as well when you write things down
it forces you to think through them when
you talk about it with other people you
get some of that out of your system so I
think that's powerful separate work from
home right so you're gonna go in this
horrible place don't bring that home
with you how do you do that change out
of your uniform get to put you put you
put your flip-flops on put your put your
shorts on and your t-shirt when you get
home don't wear your uniform don't wear
your police uniform don't wear your your
doctors don't wear your scrubs home take
them off don't wear your EMT uniform
home don't just don't do that change and
then compartmentalize because
you don't you you got a compartmentalize
these bad things and and I guess maybe
that could be construed in a negative
way like I'm saying lockdown you know hi
come put them in a compartment and put
them away I'm not saying that I'm saying
separate because I because what I'm
saying I'm not saying lock things we'll
put things in a box and lock them there
I'm not saying that at all I'm actually
saying the opposite right about them
talk about them with your friends you
know talk about what you experienced
where you file all that stuff it's gonna
make you feel better but keep it
separate from people that don't have
that experience right so you don't want
to drag home the war to your wife and
your kids you don't want to drag home
the the ER to your wife and your kids
you don't want to drag home the
perpetrators and the horrible things you
see as a police officer you don't wanna
drag those home every day mmm so
compartmentalize and I think those are
the things that I've done that mmm
that I think it felt me